hello everyone this next game was played
in 1853 in Vienna between Joseph Michiko
and the Austrian chess master and
journalist earn bought beer and a lot of
you probably have heard of all beer as
he introduced the four bears counter
again with the Kings gambit and tariffs
even said one that his counter gambit
completely refused the Kings gambit idea
and interestingly enough foam beer is
black in this game and he doesn't go for
his own invention but he plays it to the
standard way so II for 5f4 and he
captures on f4 so folk beer accepts the
gambit we have a knight to f3 g 5h for G
for Knight to e5 Knight to f6
we have a Knight to c3 and I would be
six kicking the knife so much hero plays
Knight to c4 we have Bishop to e7 d4
white really wants to capture the a pawn
now but this will be problematic because
white plays a nice to h5 and is
threatening to capture on h4 so we have
Bishop to e2 and form replace Bishop
captures on h4 would check and here
material plays working to d2 and we have
Queen to g5 a very nice move as it's a
threaten the discovery with f3 so much a
surprise came to d3 and here we have 90
c6 by fog beer also with some IDs of 94
check so much Eversole says he plays a 3
and we have Bishop to f2 that's rising
threatening that d4 pawn so we have nice
to d5 Bishop captures on d4 and now nice
Cather's on c7 check and the Pope who
plays King to d8 and the white decides
not to capture the rook he decides to
bring back the knight said to help with
the defense of the King so he plays
Knight to d5 and here a former plays f5
trying to try to go for this pawn and
somehow gets to the king and the Machiko
plays Knight captures on d6 and this is
a very interesting position
is threatening nice to have 7:14 the
king and the Queen well and the rook but
that's of less importance and he also
has this nice file
he said the white queen is x-raying the
black King and these Knights do look
kind of dangerous but what doesn't have
time for any of this as vulgar plays F
captures any for would check and well
there aren't that many ideas the White
has here he probably he could move to d2
but then he was a lot of discoveries
again and well this night is hanging on
d5 so white rice came to c4 and now he's
threatening night to f7 check again and
this is a very very nice position as it
I mean hog bear is actually threatening
a forced checkmate in nine news and
vulgar finds it so that's why I call the
game for bears amazing King hunt and
former plays Queen captures on d5 we
check the king is already on the fourth
ranked cellphone bird decides to invite
him into fifth rank we have King
captures on d5 and now nice to f6 check
the King has only one square to go to
the net is c4 so all the bird continues
to the hunt Bishop to e6 check only
square for King is b5 we have eight six
check King to a four and now b5 check
and the King has no more squares so then
I have to capture Knight captures on b5
we have a capture some b5 with check
King capture some b5 and now for bear
invites the King to the sixth rank we
have ripped to a5 check King has the
Catherine c6 only move we have Bishop to
g5 check in to d6 only move and now nice
the eh checkmate so yeah a very nice
game in the beautiful King hunt by fog
beardy austrane chess master and
journalist and yeah so not not in
everyday position to see a this is
something like this that the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here hope you're all
having a great Saturday and I'll see you
soon